[Musique]
ben
lutter contre la désinformation sous
toutes ses formes
bah c'est notre mission mais ça devrait
être la sphère de tous un effort de
société un peu partout en occident on a
compris que ce combat doit commencer tôt
sur les bancs d'école
c'est le cas dans plusieurs
établissements scolaires du québec on
voulait voir de près comment au
sensibilise les jeunes dangers de la
désinformation à l'ère du numérique une
école secondaire publique de la vallée
du richelieu nous a ouvert ses portes
quand as tu entendu parler de
désinformation pour la première fois
pourquoi c'est important de lutter
contre la désinformation selon toi et
enfin est ce que les jeunes de ta
génération sont assez sensibilisés au
phénomène de la désinformation car
descente est chaud à l'acte dans quel
contexte l'idée vous est venu ça répond
à quel besoin ça réponde à quels besoins
départ jamais on n'a été autant
bombardés d'informations on est on sûr
chargé d'information qu'on n'arrive plus
à traiter
je dire quelque chose à faire et arrive
un certain dans notre homme pour pouvoir
avec le de l'oeil à plus de compromis à
faire de ce côté là il faut se dire
voici on a une mission ici est d'aider
nos jeunes à comprendre ses enjeux très
clairement de nommer les menaces on peut
faire quelque chose d'un code de
conduite qu'on peut adopter de bons
réflexes à adopter
je pense qu'il faut être vigilant il de
se rappeler que s'est terminé le temps
où on était passif mais pour vous vous
êtes nés en 2002 2003 ce talent jamais
vraiment existé d'une certaine façon ce
n'est dans ces univers là le monde
d'avant internet c'est un peu la
préhistoire
ces jeunes sont nés en même temps que
les médias sociaux mais le paradoxe
c'est qu'ils n'en connaissent pas tous
les pièges
vu qu'on a commenté alexandre fois les
serments et toxiques parce que nos
parents et à l'épaule gauche de ma vie
nous on ne personnes soit à qui sait si
facebook des câbles mais comment ça
s'enseigne la lutte à la désinformation
nicolas wallet leur présente tout un
éventail d'outils pratiques qui leur
permettent de départager le vrai du faux
je vous ai soumis 10 images ce que vous
pensez que c'est une information qui est
vrai ou pas quand il traverse
l'atlantique dans un tonneau en bois
haut on voit que les avis semblent
partagés faut pour la majorité
obs il ya deux choses qu'on aurait pu
vérifier facilement d'abord l'image on
peut faire une recherche inversée est
aussi placée par exemple le site de
france 3 régions ici dans le moteur de
recherche du des codex donc du quotidien
le monde
ce qu'on va faire ma la deuxième étape
de notre activité et comment c'est reçu
ce message là jusqu'à présent par les
par les élèves quel genre de rétroaction
vous avez ils sont interpellés parce
qu'ils se sont pas posé six conteneurs
vraiment c'est que ce que j'aime c'est
que j'ai pu consommer l'information de
la même façon maintenant c'est pas mal
saumon et passion les tensions
pédagogique ces voix si vous êtes des
citoyens
vous n'êtes pas des consommateurs vous
êtes des citoyens dans une démocratie ça
s'accompagne de droit bien sûr mais
aussi de responsabilités la
responsabilité de bien s'informer à
l'ère du numérique et des médias sociaux
un principe rapidement assimilé par les
élèves
quand on prend le temps de le renseigner
bien sûr que l'information
l'api demande si on ne peut la
conscience que ça peut être fausse
information sans surprise ça c'était au
complet qui mal informé par rapport aux
fins de taux de mon fils
facebook ça doit prendre le fric est
second au pire on prend pas
nécessairement le temps de kaboré les
informations si on raconte n'importe
quoi sans partage les portes il ya
urgence à traiter de cette question
parce que l'on parle des reposte factuel
se dire que les fines compte plus alors
là les faits en fait sont moins
importants que l'idée que tu te fais des
choses ton émotions de ton feeling
les titres accrocheurs sensationnaliste
c'est pour nous attirer l'émotion en
fait tu m'en donnes il vient un temps où
l'émotion prend dessus ils nous
empêchent de réfléchir
aussitôt enseigner aussitôt apprécié
l'expérience plaît aux élèves
convaincu de la pertinence de ce type de
courbe il ya tellement de fausses
informations constituent qu il faut
croire qu'il faut pas croire qu'ils le
coup nous explique vraiment équipe et
vous avez toutes ces ressources là
utiliser les poubelles peau sont aussi
vrai ou faux je trouve que c'est
vraiment important parce que c'est
quelque chose qu'on apprend
habituellement dans les écoles ya
beaucoup d'écriture le privilège d'avoir
un prof
il ya en plus autant passionné dans
votre cas vous dans quelle mesure vous
aviez uno les ressources les outils
nécessaires pour aller de l'avant en
cours comme ça il ya des ressources qui
existent
le nerf de la guerre et si c'est le
temps preuve qu'ils disent elles aborder
ces questions là bas qu'il faut il
essentiellement c'est ce que j'ai fait
sur votre part ou bien sûr c'est comme
ça qu'on confie c'est ce que je vous dis
c'est vrai pour combien de mes collègues
qui investissent dans leur temps comme
ça il ya des ressources qui existent
encore une fois mais c'est le temps qui
nous manque pour arriver à tous à tout
ficelé ça pour que ça donne un coup je
peux pas laisser partir les jeunes comme
ça au cégep puis de commencer leur vie
adulte sans leur avoir même en parler
tout ça chante experts mon devoir de le
faire quand je pars la maison six élèves
chasse est confiant que ça laisse
effectivement une trace au ministère
l'éducation il ya clairement une volonté
politique pour que ce type de contenus
pédagogiques soient favorisés d'ailleurs
la toute dernière mouture du plan
d'action numérique en éducation en fait
une priorité
là dessus le ministre jean françois
roberge n'ont pas été en mesure cette
semaine de nous accorder une entrevue
ça nous empêche pas de parler des autres
options d autres initiatives qui
existent en ce moment et d'abord la
fédération professionnelle des
journalistes du québec qui offre aux
écoles le programme 30 secondes avant
d'y croire des simples des journalistes
volontaires vont dans les écoles
partager leur expertise leurs
connaissances avec les enseignants avec
les élèves
à l'échelle canadienne y est le géant
google qui soutient financièrement le
programme activités de l'organisme
civique ce même principe en france avec
le programme autres les lignes qui est
soutenu par plusieurs médias français
mais en france l'aide de l'état pèse
plus lourd dans la balance
imaginez quinze mille enseignants
français à tous les ans sont forts mais
reçoivent une formation publique sur la
désinformation en ligne le budget
ministériel annuel pour ce type de
formation la frisée 9 millions $ alors
au canada et au québec
est-ce qu'on devra en faire davantage
pour favoriser ce type d'enseignement
qu'en pensez vous des douleurs